also making news where in the world are
Harry and Megan last public appearance
nearly six weeks ago November 9th places
Harry and Meghan could be hiding out la
where her mom Doria lives or Canada were
Megan shot suits what are you talking
about possible celebrity accomplices
keeping the couple on the DL first
suspect Oprah I'm just so proud of her
for being able to stand in what works
for her and Harry and what is the truth
for them how they want to raise their
baby
there's no way prying eyes could
infiltrate MS OHS 90 million dollar
Montecito mansion next up George in a
mall the Clooney's have a home in LA
she's a really kind and smart and
intelligent young woman and and they're
a really wonderful loving couple Amal
has reportedly given Megan advice on how
to settle into London life and there's
rumors Archie has had play dates with
the twins actually there's many people
who could be entertaining the Royals for
the holidays Serena Williams Priyanka
and Nick the beckham's lots of celebs
attended the Royal Wedding and today new
headlines claim Megan was smart to
invite a listeners even when she didn't
know well like Oprah and the Clooney's
because now they're Team Megan she's
someone who's very concerned about
Branigan Megan is a networker par
excellence so how does the royal family
feel well if they're upset no one
showing it today the Queen and Harry's
dad Charles opened Parliament in London
Harry and Megan's official six-week
break is over around the New Year and
they could return with a big surprise
they may be using this trip as an
opportunity to look at some houses a
second home in the state
[Music]